vielleicht haben sie ansatzweise
zumindest eine antwort für diesen ja
eigentlich unglaublichen fall der papa
von frau karrenbauer hat schon den
impftermin der will sich impfen lassen
unbedingt der hat das glück dass er
eigentlich einer der ersten ist in
berlin weil er in einem heim ist das
verimpft jetzt kommt der chor ohne
ausbruch in diesem heim und das ist der
grund weswegen er der noch gesund ist
nicht geimpft wird
es tut mir furchtbar leid ich kann das
nicht erklären gerade und weil ich ich
bin niedersachse ich habe ähnliche fälle
da sage ich gerne gleich was zu bei mir
auch aus dem heimatland
ich kann versprechen und zusagen dass
ich gerne mit der berliner politik
kontakt aufnehmen und dass ich in
erfahrung bringen warum diese
entscheidung genauso getroffen worden
aber verstehe erstmal die emotionalität
und die tragik und das ist noch das was
ich vorhin gesagt habe wir haben den
menschen über monate gesagt wenn der
impfstoff da ist dann wird es besser und
jetzt scheint es hier noch eine
situation zu geben die noch mal wieder
zum verhindern und blockieren führt und
das ist nicht gut und da geht vertrauen
lieber klingbeil ich nehme hier da muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen tun sie das bitte
weil er sitzt negativ getestet er wird
jeden tag getestet er ist noch negativ
aber uns allen ist doch klar dass der
vater von fliegern die ihr letztes geben
und völlig am rande der verzweiflung
sind aber eben auch cupid patienten
betreuen im haus das er dort in einem
hotspot sitzt und ich ihm nicht erklären
kann warum er das zimmer nicht mehr
verlassen darf und das tue ich seit 22
tagen
aber ich merke und es geht um einsamkeit
es geht um so viele viele
begrifflichkeiten aber vor allem wo ist
der rettende impfstoff und ich sage
ihnen ganz ehrlich ich setze schon heuer
und jeden abend da und sage mache licht
was tue ich eigentlich ist das was ich
tue wissend dass mein vater gesund nach
dort sitzt aber sich jederzeit
infizieren könnte ist das nicht
unterlassene hilfeleistung und das werfe
ich im staat vor
wer übernimmt dafür die verantwortung
wenn mein vater jetzt eher krank und
stirbt
das ist ja ein fall ein ganz besonders
emotional geschilderte frau karrenbauer
aber einer wie es ihn zu hunderten
gehabt vielleicht zu teilen
den vergangenen tagen also ich will das
1 1
ich will das gerne zu sagen dass wir
morgen telefonieren und dass ich da mich
mal schlau macht aber das was programm
bei anspricht ist natürlich das was ich
jetzt die letzten tage auch erlebt habe
die menschen sehen im fernsehen es geht
los ich lege die anrufe als war ich mir
auch bundestagsabgeordneter als
abgeordneter die wollen wissen wie ist
das hat jetzt kontakt mit dem landrat
der sagt morgen fahren die mobilen impf
teams los der impfstoff ist gestern
gekommen also der ist jetzt am samstag
angeliefert worden so und es warten alle
darauf und das muss jetzt losgehen und
die alten und pflegeheime das will ich
auch mal sagen wir haben ganz ganz viel
über schulen diskutiert und kitas das
ist total wichtig aber wir haben viel zu
lange nicht hingeguckt was in den alten
und pflegeheim passiert und die tragisch
nur eine sind die tragischen fälle sind
da die hohen zahlen sind da und deswegen
ist auch so wichtig das ist da los geht
und dass endlich was passiert jetzt in
den einrichtungen